oh pardon pardon à la basse et c'est pas
faut changer là-bas faut chaud vous
savez le croire cycliste qui a battu le
record de l'heure ah si si si si ces
photos nous lui avons demandé de venir
pour l'émission est très en avance il
s'est dopé peut-être fauchon fauchon
s'il vous plaît pourriez-vous venir vous
asseoir en face de monsieur peillon
quelle allure
on a beau dire mais le sport ça rend
beau bonjour monsieur beauchamp a je
suis content de voir de près
oui parce que je vous admire beaucoup à
oui vous avez vous avez une façon de
[Rires]
mérite dont un ce que j'étais dessus
l'année dernière dans le paris roubaix
quand vous avez fait que deuxième en nom
d'une pipe
derrière sur landel a même relancé et
bien je hollandais il s'était dopé mais
vous n'étiez pas de place je suis bien
sur wii il avait mis du super tant qu'à
faire quand on a les moyens mais du tout
ce record de l'heure quel scandale
1 c'est vrai ce qu'ils disent les gens
n'ont que 100 le doping vous n'auriez
pas battu ce record de l'heure alors
écoutez écoutez coûteuse je ne voudrais
pas mais je fais mais je répète encore
pour la dernière fois que je n'étais pas
dopé au vigorelli non
relisez l'article que j'ai publié un anr
et f
vous écrivez oui d'ailleurs je vous
admire tellement que je garde tous les
journaux qui parlent de vaud est
justement
dernièrement ils disent est extrêmement
ce record ne sera pas homologué
parce que lorsque fauchon s'est soumis
au contrôle anti doping l'éprouvette
s'est mise à bouillir ce c'est vrai ça
du possible
monsieur on fait attention photo dc que
lorsque vous étiez descendre de descendu
de vélo vous étiez mis à danser le
charleston pendant cinq ou dix minutes
alors évidemment c'est un fait en fait
j'ai pas fait mais dites-moi détruits
nous sommes entre nous
franchement youtube comme un type un
petit peu de paix je n'étais pas tous pu
vivre les 100 milliards
j'étais sous contrôle médical c'est
différent je n'étais pas dopé mon
soigneur me donne des vitamines parce
que ça j'ai pas envie de faire du vélo
mais ça oui mais quand même il disait
aussi que d'ailleurs je les veux envoyer
votre soigneur justement qui tous les
deux trois tours vous donner quelque
chose à à croquer c'était quoi je sais
quoi quoi je ne peux je comprends pas la
quête du commun écoutez moi bien je
parle doucement et votre soigneur vous
donner quelque chose à croquer c'est
quoi
c'était qu'à croquer qui équipe un bon
tirage du 18
petite petite friandise la loterie signe
avec de la crème de grillades sur le
podium et des bonbons durs envers votre
ami votre chose mais je sais pas moi
bientôt des sucettes avec un peu indique
qu'un seul à me demander si les juniors
de l'est vitamine c que si c'était du
dopé il me l'aurait dit qu'est ce que ça
fait quand on avale ça alors là c'est
comme voler ou quand on [ __ ] syrienne
dans le ventre on s'ennuie au pauvre
toujours pareil et puis c'est dur tandis
que quand le soigneur vous avez mangé
ces petites choses
alors d'abord on a le temps
et puis et puis alors et surtout on a
l'impression que ça descende tout le
temps vous savez on décerne des changes
alors forcément ça ah oui puis il disait
justement des gens n'ont que le dernier
tour de piste vous les avez fait à toute
allure en sifflant la marche turque
comme ça facile
[Rires]
la marche turque de mozart ce jeudi et
s'est pas fait attention
alors finalement ce record ils vont le
meut loguy
comme je l'écris dans mon article
enfin il ne sera pas homologué parce que
naturellement qu'ils m'ont chinoise
paraît aussi que vous avez giflé le
docteur du contrôle anti doping pas
seulement ça il a eu sa base il l'a
mérité et l'a eu mais j'ai couru plus
d'une heure vingt 20 minutes entre ans
c'est pas c'est pas réglementaire mais
ça je peux pas m'arrêter alors qu'est-ce
que vous avalez la nation cherche un
petit cochon que tu vaux où ils ont
petit endroit même pas mais à tanger
sous contrôle médical avant alors au
revoir monsieur fau son au revoir
[Musique]